wenn jemand wie sie Frau neiswanger hört
dass
z.B knapp über 60% auch der SPD
Mitglieder unzufrieden mit der
Ausgestaltung des Bürgergelds sind was
sagt ihn
das ich will mal anders anfangen ich bin
halt ein Mensch der Leist also für mich
ist Leistung was wert und für mich sind
Werte was wert und für mich zählt die
Leistung und mein Grundvertrag ist halt
Arbeit gegen Geld und ich habe Menschen
im im
Niedriglohnsektor und ich bin dankbar
dass die morgens noch
kommen führen sie mit in diese Gespräche
die ihnen sagen warum soll ich das
eigentlich Gott sei Dank habe ich es
nicht aber von Kollegen ich meine ich
bin ja sehr viel im Ehrenamt unterwegs
und in Verbänden organisiert und da höre
ich das durchaus dass also gerade aus
meinem Netzwerk mir jemand gesagt hat
die haben leider aufgehört und die
melden sich beim
Arbeitsamt was würden Sie sich
wünschen Z wenn ich mir was wünschen
darf wünsche ich mir zuerst mal Frieden
auf dieser Welt das ist im mal
und me was das was das ang fr Werte das
Werte wieder was zählen dass das Wort
was zählt auch ein unangenehmes Wort
muss ausgesprochen werden dürfen
Bürgergeld Lohn die Frage ob sich
Leistung lohnt ja genau dass sich
Leistung wieder lohnt
ja aber sozial also ich will das jetzt
nicht ich will nicht da stehen als als
unsozial
aber Leistung muss ich lohnen ne es geht
ja um ein Gefühl von Gerechtigkeit genau
von von Fairness das irgendwie gerade
abhanden kommt ein bisschen oder Herr
Stum wie würden Sie es beschreiben ja
und ich glaube diese bürgergelddebatte
ist für die SPD ganz ganz fantal ich
fand jetzt interessant dass der
Ministerpräsident von Brandenburg das
als großes Problem beschrieben hat Wutke
der dieses Jahr vor einer sehr sehr
schwierigen Wahl steht und ich glaube er
spricht das aus was manch anderer denkt
es hat jetzt innerhalb von 13 Monaten
zweimal 12przentige Erhöhung des
Bürgergeldes gegeben und die SPD ist ja
nun Herr küner weiß es viel besser als
ich aber gegründet als allgemeiner
deutscher Arbeiterverein also ist ja
eine Partei der Arbeit und wo die Arbeit
auch immer ein Wert war über den über
das Geld verdienen hinaus ja
identitätsstiften absolut und soziale
Bindung schaffen und und und und ich
glaube deswegen ist diese Diskussion
ganz ganz gefährlich und da bin ich eben
bei diesem Punkt den ich gerade schon
mal versucht habe zu machen dass ich
finde dass die alle drei Parteien in
dieser Koalition angesichts der Lage
Stichwort nicht wettbewerbsfähig
Stichwort Rezession wirklich jetzt mit
Vorschlägen kommen müssen wo sie auch
etwas von ihren eigenen Glaubenssätzen
abrücken ich höre sehr viel Dogmen und
Doktrinen und wenn ich bei der SPD bei
Herr Mütze nicht der ja ohnehin so eine
Figur aus den aus den 80er Jahren ist
höre es gibt grundsätzlich keine
sozialkürzung das wird nicht
funtionieren in dieser Lage wir haben
jetzt die Lage wir haben kein
Wirtschaftswunder wie in den 50er Jahren
und es müssen jetzt alle Zugeständnisse
machen und wenn diese Regierung die ja
nach Herrn Scholz Worten wiedergewählt
werden will die soll ja noch mehrere
Legislaturperioden regieren so hat er es
ja
20121 gesagt werden sie sich auch
bewegen müssen und dass die SPD niemand
will den Sozialstaat in Deutschland
schreddern aber wir haben nur mal ein
sehr natürlich gibt Leute die sch wollen
aber sehr sehr hohes sozialstaatsniveau
Herr Herr künert wir arbeiten am
wenigsten es gibt auch Sozialdemokraten
die sagen wir müssen mehr arbeiten das
sind aber immer hbeans Herr Steinbrück
z.B sagt wir müssen mehr arbeiten wir
arbeiten viel weniger auch als
Österreicher oder Portugiesen wir haben
natürlich ein enorm also wir haben ein
sozial Produkt insgesamt von über einer
Billion das ist diese Zahl mit den 12
Null das ist schon eine Menge und dann
zu sagen das ist alles Tabu das ist
finde ich Politik ähm Verweigerung und
Frau nales Chefin der BA hat neulich
auch gesagt dass z.B dieses ganze
frühverahrentungsproblem groß sei und
dass das im Grunde ein Fehler gewesen
sei Rente mit 63 und sie hat nicht die
Rente mit also jetzt wird's wirklich
Einführung der die Einführung der wir
haben doch das große Problem mit dem
Fachkräftemangel und die Einführung der
R die Lösung dafür ist dass die Leute
die am längsten gearbeitet haben die 45
und mehr Jahre oft Vollzeit hinter sich
haben 63 sondern mittlerweile mit 64
bald mit 65 etwas früher in Rente gehen
können nicht müssen niemand muss in
Deutschland in Rente gehen das sind die
ersten die ihnen einfallen wenn sie an
Fachkräfte Mangel denken dass die noch
länger sollen K das wollen sie im
Rentensystem was reformieren
grundsätzlich oder sagen Sie das bleibt
immer ich habe sie gerade gefragt ob sie
finden ob sie es gerecht finden dass
wenn sie wenn sie am Rentensystem was
ändern wollen sie als allererstes den
Blick auf die richten die genau ihre
Kriterien eigentlich erfüllen die sehr
lange gearbeitet haben die Vollzeit
gearbeitet haben und denen wir die
Möglichkeit geben ein bisschen früher
rauszugehen ich würde erstmal auf z.B
sowas wie die
frauenerwerbstätigkeitsquote gucken 30%
der Frauen arbeiten Vollzeit aber 80%
sagen sie würden gerne mehr arbeiten da
liegt ein großes Potenzial
beispielsweise dr Rente mit 67 ist vor
17 Jahren eingeführt worden seitdem sind
wir trotz vonakrise einem spdmann ja
Franz Müntefering damals hat das
exekutiert nicht so viel Rücksicht
genommen auf die auf die
Befindlichkeiten der Partei Frau Frau
esken diskutiert allen Ernstes über eine
vier Tage Woche mit vollem Lohnausgleich
ihr Landesverband Berlin der SPD hat auf
dem SPD Bundesparteitag eine 32 Stunden
Woche bei vollem Lohnausgleich und bei
nichts antasten an sozialen Leistungen
gefordert in einem Antrag und aus einer
das ist aus einer anderen Welt her Stum
jetzt haben sie nun wirklich alle alle
Begriffe die ihn eingefallen sind sinden
einal aufgezählt und zusammengepackt
aber das also ich muss mich schon sehr
wundern weil das ist ja es ist ja nicht
so wie Sie behaupten dass in Zeiten wo
jetzt die Haushaltslage schwierig ist
nirgendwo rangegangen worden wäre wir
haben einen Spar beseschluss im Dezember
gefasst der sich auf ganz viele Gruppen
in dieser Gesellschaft auswirkt wir
haben vorhin über die Landwirte
gesprochen dass über eine Milliarde
Streichung bei den humanitären Hilfen
was sehr hart ist beispielsweise mit
drin da sind auch aus dem
bürgergeldsystem Streichung mit drin
gewesen und anderes mehr es ist aber mit
nichten so dass in diesem Land an alle
Gruppen rangegangen worden wäre ähm weil
leider dafür die politischen Mehrheiten
nicht da sind insbesondere der sehr
vermögende Teil in dieser Gesellschaft
bei dem alle in ihren Sonntagsreden
immer bekennen in Krisenzeiten müssen
die starken Schultern mehr tragen D muss
Solidarität gelten da meine ich nicht
jetzt Unternehmen die ein gutes Jahr
gemacht haben sondern ich meine Leute
die auf riesigen Erbschaften oder
ähnlichem sitzen an die geht die Politik
zum leitwesen von mir und meiner Partei
weil wir die Mehrheiten dafür nicht
haben eben genau nicht dran wir reden
darüber dass Leute mehr arbeiten sollen
dass bei Sozialleistung was gemacht
werden sollen dass Subventionen bei
Landwirten abgebaut werden sollen wir
schieben einen riesigen Investitionsstau
in Deutschland in bundländern und
Kommunen für die öffentliche
Infrastruktur vor uns her wir müssten
mehr machen bei Digitalisierung bei
Katastrophen und Hochwasserschutz und
andere mehr aber die den nahliegendsten
Gedanken nämlich zu sagen bei ein paar
wenig die ohne Leistung wir reden ja die
ganze Zeit über Leistung die ohne eigene
Leistung zu riesigen Vermögen gekommen
sind da gehen wir nicht dran warum wird
darüber keine politische Diskussion
geführt warum fordern sie das nicht sie
regieren doch mit der FDP ja in der und
damit ist die Antwort ja auch schon
gegeben da drauf warum das unter den
mehrheitsf wäre mit Herrn märz nicht
anders die Bereitschaft ist dort nicht
da und das finde ich ich finde das
unmöglich dass wir diese
leistungsdiskussion nur zwischen den
Armen und den Allerärmsten her Kü W ist
bei der SPD die Bereitschaft
substanziell beim Sozialetat was zu
machen wir werden doch beim Haushalt
2025 wir haben ja das gerade schon
angeschnitten wird es do noch ganz
andere Verteilungskämpfe geben übrigens
auch Verteilungskämpfe die in die
Gesellschaft reingehen wo ist das
Angebot der SPD über ihren Schatten der
Dogmen der Doktrinen zu
springeninar weil es wird ja auch ein
von einer hohen Steuerbelastung
gesprochen die wir in der Tat haben mm
so und ich zahle gern Steuer wenn ich
gewinne ma und jetzt haben wir aber die
Kommunen die dürfen wir mal gar nicht
aus dem Auge verlieren und mittlerweile
ist es so dass ein Dorf oder eine
Gemeinde die braucht die Genehmigung für
den Haushalt der muss ausgeglichen sein
jetzt kriegen die ja vieles aufgedrückt
wo sie gar keinen Einfluss haben und
dann ist das Ergebnis die Antwort dann
müssen sie an den Hebesätzen drehen also
ich bin jetzt ein Unternehmen ich sitze
in einem Ort ich zahle auch gerne meine
Steuer aber was bekom komme ich denn
dafür außer dass mir jetzt angedroht
wird die Grundsteuer wird erhöht also
der Hebesatz damit die Grundsteuer oder
der Hebesatz für die Gewerbesteuer und
dann fallen Sätze und da möchte ich das
wöring auch mal nennen bis sie müssen
das tun an die Bürgermeister oder wer
auch verantwortlich ist bis zur
erdrosselungswirkung B bis zur
erdrosselungswirkung und da freue ich
mich nicht über so ein Begri wer sagt
das ja die Menschen die dann veranlassen
dass also die nächst höhere Ebene die
sagt sowas
an die die habe ich bei ein
Neujahrsempfang
diese Botschaft jetzt gerade auch gehört
und da da muss ich sagen da kommen einem
dann schon Gedanken äh bin ich hier noch
richtig
erdrosselungswirkung wir haben
mittlerweile Hebesätze von 1000% in
einigen Gemeinden super
ne das können Sie den Bürger nicht mehr
vermitteln also das ist mein Problem ich
habe die Leute ich habe die Firma gern
ich füre Sie auch gern hab
einkommenenssteuersatz der liegt
jenseits der 40% weil es eine
Personengesellschaft ist also ich
verdiene Million gehen über 400.000 € in
die Steuer dann möchte ich aber auch was
davon haben wo ist denn der
Service der mir als Gegenleistung kommt
mhm ich zahl gern Steuer ich verlager
nicht irgendwas Investition ins Ausland
weil ich habe nur ich habe nur diesen
Standort andere Unternehmen
könen die ersten ich habe in meinem
Netzwerk gestern noch mit jemanden
gesprochen es ging um zwei investien mhm
Deutschland China Deutschland Brasilien
und beide beide sind nicht in
Deutschland das ist jetzt im Moment noch
kein Problem aber das hat ja eine
Folgewirkung klar die sind weg ja das
ist der Punkt wenn die erstmal weg sind
sind sie sind sie weg das ist der Punkt
Frau GM sie wollten gerade die ganze
Zeit ja also ich glaube schon dass es
wichtig ist eben zu sehen dass man im
sozialen Sicherheitssystem natürlich
sicherstellen muss
dass jeder aufgefangen wird der nicht
kann aber ich glaube es genau das ist
das ist für viele gar keine Frage aber
es ist auch wichtig genau es ist aber
auch wichtig eben aufzupassen dass man
nicht an vielen verschiedenen Stellen
versucht umzuverteilen dass man nicht an
vielen verschiedenen Stellen versucht
noch mal zusätzlich umzuverteilen also
es ist glaube ich sehr sehr wichtig dass
man ein gutes soziales Netz hat gerade
auch weil natürlich
die Verteilungsfragen wichtiger werden
und auch die ungleichhe hat natürlich
eine große Rolle spielt auch für
politische Entscheidungen aber wir haben
dann ganz viele
umverteilungsche Diskussionen beim
klimageld wurde diskutiert ob man das
nicht sozial Staffeln soll bei der
gesetzlichen
Rentenversicherung ist die Diskussion
soll man innerhalb der gesetzlichen
Rentenversicherung auch noch umverteilen
und so haben wir dann eine Diffusion von
ganz vielen verschiedenen Mechanismen
die natürlich alle was kosten die am
Ende dazu führen dass diejenigen die
wirklich arbeiten und auch einzahlen z.B
Falle der Rentenversicherung dass die
natürlich die relativ gut verdienen aber
nicht sehr gut in der gesetzlichen
Rentenversicherung z.B ist das mittlere
Einkommen bei Steuerklasse 1 2600 € und
dann gibt es Diskussionen die darauf
abzielen die Menschen die dann mehr
verdienen
hin heranzuziehen um denen die zu wenig
Rente bekommen aus dem System was
zukommen zu lassen und das führt
natürlich dazu dass die Leute die
tatsächlich arbeiten und von ihrer von
ihrem Einkommen auch leben wollen dass
die natürlich zukommen zunehmend
frustriert werden und ich glaube das ist
auch wirklich ein Problem ich glaube wir
müssen schon schauen dass wir jeden
absichern aber dass am Ende dann eben
auch Arbeit und Leistung lohnt und man
den Menschen ganz klar macht dass eine
Wertschätzung gibt und man auch dieses
Sicherungssystem eben nicht dafür da ist
als Alternative genau den Punkt würde
ich ger noch einmal aufgreifen bevor wir
noch zu einem letzten Gedanken kommen K
was was denken Sie wenn Sie das hören
dass Frau neonger sagt gibt's Leute die
hören auf und und gehen zum Amt und
sagen lohnt sich für mich nicht mehr die
diese leistungsgerechtigkeitsdiskussion
die dahinter steht ist real die begegnet
mir in jedem Gespräch und in jeder
Veranstaltung und ich finde die hat eine
absolute Daseinsberechtigung wir sind an
dem Punkt in Deutschland das Teil ich
als Sozialdemokrat auch mit unserem
Programm im Rücken bei dem man mit Fug
und Recht fragen kann ob für Leute die
in der untersten Lohngruppe Vollzeit
arbeiten der Abstand noch groß genug ist
zu dem
h auf haben nicht die hören auf jetzt
bisschenon
Menschen jetzt ist die Frage was geben
wir als politische Antwort da drauf ich
w ich möchte bitte dazu einmal ausführen
weil wir auch eben über jetzt
Sozialleistung gesprochen haben die so
viel werden und dann wird meine Partei
was ja auch in Ordnung ist damit
assoziiert wir halten den sozialstad
hoch und es schwingt immer so ein
bisschen mit sozialstaatliche Leistung
das sind alles begünstig le für faule
Menschen die nicht mehr nicht meh ich
hab das niemlichellt aber das schwingt
im Ohr mit ganz viel geben wir aus und
haben wir und haben wir ganz viel geben
wir aus und haben wir erhöht in dieser
Wahlperiode für Leute die arbeiten aber
trotzdem Unterstützung brauchen wir
haben 800 000 Menschen die sind im
Bürgergeld aber nicht weil sie
arbeitslos wären sondern weil sie
aufstockende Leistung dort kriegen die
Arbeiten aber es reicht nicht weil der
niedrigoh im untersten Segment zu
niedrig ist wir haben 4,5 Millionen
Menschen die in Haushalten leben die
wohngeldberechtigt sind das sind
arbeitende Menschen oder Leute mit
kleinen Renten im Alter nach
jahrzehntelanger Arbeit die zu wenig
haben und deswegen die Unterstützung der
Solidargemeinschaft brauchen
Kinderzuschlag und anderes mehr kommt
dazu ich möchte damit sagen wir haben
ein gerechtigkeitsproblem im Bereich der
untersten Löhne aber das ist eben auch
darin zu suchen dass Leute von ihrer
Arbeit trotz Mindestlohn trotz Erhöhung
die wir durchgedrückt haben gegen viele
das ist für die nicht reicht ich frage
mich wo der Aufschrei bleibt dass Leute
Vollzeit arbeiten gehen und damit nicht
über die Runden kommen und wir alle als
Solidargemeinschaft das finan kommt
direkt zu Ihnen zurück machen Sie Frau
grim also ich ich kann da nicht folgen
ist es nicht eher so dass sie setzen
doch diese Rahmenbedingungen sie haben
noch also nicht Sie persönlich um
Himmels willen aber es war die Politik
die Regierung in der letzten Jahre die
Arbeit in diesem Land immer teurer
gemacht haben doch einer der Gründe
warum es sich nicht mehr lohnt ist
faktisch einfach falsch diese Bundes
diese Bundesregierung die Ampel Ampel
lass mich a die Ampelkoalition hat für
die Midi Jobs beispielsweise das sind
die Jobs bis 2000 € die man nicht bei
den Steuern entlasten kann weil die
Leute im Wesentlichen keine Steuern
zahlen hat die sozialabgabenlast gesenkt
damit bei denen tatsächlich auch was
ankommt mal haben den Mindestlohn erhöht
und sehen uns jetzt konfrontiert mit
Angriffen von politischen Parteien die
sich enthalten haben in namentlicher
Abstimmung im Bundestag als es um 12 €
Mindestlohn ging die fanden das
angemessen dass Leute weiter für 10,40 €
die Stunde arbeiten und erzählen uns und
diesen 6 Millionen Menschen da in den
niedrigsten lohnbereichen jetzt eine
große Geschichte dass es ja so ungerecht
mit der Arbeit in Deutschland zugehen
würde ja das stimmt zum Teil weil Leute
so wenig Geld verdienen und d
Arbeit ist zu teuer Energie ist zu teuer
all diese Dinge sind zu wo ist im
Niedriglohnbereich die Arbeit jetzt zu
teuer bei demjenigen der 200 ein paar
zerquetschte brutto bei Vollzeit
Mindestlohn in Deutschland bekommen
wofür ist jetzt für den Arbeit zu teuer
er stur bitte ich find auch die SPD
macht sich da manchmal ein bisschen zu
schlanken Fuß also wenn man mal bedenkt
dass die SPD seit 1998 das ist jetzt
etwas mehr als 25 Jahre her 21 Jahre
lang regiert hat entweder mit einer
Kanzlerschaft Schröder jetzt Scholz oder
eben in der großen Koalition unter Frau
Merkel wo die Erzählung der SPD immer
war inhaltlich haben wir uns
durchgesetzt in der Regierung mit der
Union die CDU will im Grunde nur den
Kanzler stellen die haben gar keine
programmatischen Ansprüche das Programm
machen wir so sie haben also in 21 von
25 Jahren regiert und sind natürlich
auch mitverantwortlich für den Zustand
der Bundeswehr es wurd dann jetzt immer
von der SPD gesagt es waren aber
christdemokratische oder CSU verteilig
Minister es war ja nicht so als hätte
die SPD da gebremst
Infrastruktur die SPD wollte anfangs mal
die Bahn Teil privatisieren in der
großen Koalition 2005 bis
2009 ich will gar nicht sprechen über
Energie und die den Verkauf von von
gasspeichern an an Gasprom und so weiter
wenn aber jetzt auch Herr Scholz neulich
bei dieser
Regierungserklärung im Stil einer
Parteitagsrede sagt in den letzten
Jahren sind sehr sehr viele Weichen
falsch gestellt worden ist das doch im
Grunde auch eine Anklage an sich selbst
also ich meine wer saß denn permanent
für die SPD mit in der Regierung und man
kann doch jetzt nicht so tun als hätte
man mit all dem auch mit dem was sie
gerade geschildert haben nun rein gar
nichts zu tun also Sie haben ja sehr
sehr lange regiert sie haben auch den
Bundesarbeitsminister oft gestellt
mehrere sie können uns kritisieren dass
wir zugelassen haben in einem Land zu
leben indem die niedrigsten Löhne im
Moment 12,41 € die Stunde betragen aber
sie wissen es besser denn sie wissen
wenn es die SP nicht gegeben hätte
würden heute immer noch Leute 7 € die
Stunde verdienen weil wir vor 10 Jahren
kein Mindestlohn eingeführt hätten und
ihn auch nicht vor 2 Jahren in einem
politischen Schritt erhöht hätten dann
hätten wir nicht 800 000 sondern
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland deren
Löhne durch die solidargemeindschaft
aufgestockt würden weil es Arbeitgeber
gibt die es für stadthaft halten Leute
mit ein paar Krümeln abzuspeisen das ist
doch die Wirklichkeit die draußen
stattfindet das ist doch nicht das hat
jetzt nicht die SPD erfunden Frau grim
also diesen ganzen so SEAG prekären
Beschäftigungssektor hat ja auch die SPD
mit zu verantworten ne ja ich GL also
Agenda 2010 sag n mal als Stichwort ist
jetzt nicht so dass das einfach vom
Himmel gefallen wäre der der riesige
Niedriglohnsektor den wir in Deutschland
über so lange Zeit hatten der hat auch
was mit ihnen zu tun das nur fürs
Protokoll ja ich meine aber ein
wichtiger Punkt ist ja dass man nicht
nur darüber diskutieren kann wie setzt
man den
Mindestlohn wie reformiert man das
steuertransfers und wo kann man bei
Vermögenssteuern oder Erbschaftssteuern
noch zusätzliche Steuereinnahmen
generieren sondern man muss ja
strukturell überlegen wie kommt dieses
Land wieder in Wachstumsdynamik und da
sind wirklich auch ganz andere Themen
aufzurufen das ist wichtig ein soziales
Sicherungsnetz zu haben es ist wichtig
dass das nicht so attraktiv ist dass man
dafür seinen Job überlegt
aufzugeben nicht finanziell vielleicht
aber das was der Arbeitsminister jetzt
vorgeschlagen hat dass man schon
irgendwie erw wartet von den Menschen
die eine Beschäftigung annehmen können
diese auch anzunehmen das ist der
richtige das ist ein richtiger Weg aber
darüber hinaus ist natürlich so dass man
überlegen muss wie kommen wir
tatsächlich wieder eine Dynamik rein das
Leistung zählt dass man auch die Kap die
die die Potenziale der Arbeitnehmer und
Arbeitnehmer tatsächlich hebt ganz
wichtiges Thema hier Bildungssystem
ganz wichtiges Thema hier Qualifizierung
und zwar zum einen Ausbildung aber eben
auch
Weiterqualifizierung und Umschulung dort
wo es Strukturwandel gibt und dann
attraktive Rahmenbedingungen schaffen
und das funktioniert nun mal eher wenn
man die Steuern senkt wenn man
attraktivere Bedingungen für die
Unternehmen generiert und nicht noch
überlegt wo man noch zugreifen kann also
das was jetzt gerade angedeutet wurde
Vermögenssteuer Erbschaftssteuer das ist
natürlich auch noch etwas was wiederum
den Standort weniger attraktiv macht die
Vermögenssteuer geht mit einem massiven
Aufwand bei der Erhebung einher man muss
ja quasi erheben welche vermögungstände
existieren und das auch
jährlich das hat man genau deswegen
abgeschafft weil der erhebungsaufwand
massiv ist und der Ertrag im Vergleich
dazu nicht signifikant die Beschäftigten
im Land würden sich manchmal auch freuen
wenn die Erhebung Ihrer steuern so
kompliziert wäre dass irgendjemand sagen
würde da können wir leider nichts machen
weil es so kompliziert ist ja aber das
ist und und letztlich brauchen wir eben
schon eine Dynamik eine Wachstumsdynamik
und jetzt ist auch das Thema
Steuerreform ja gefallen schon in der
Politik jetzt bezogen auf
Unternehmenssteuern im Prinzip wäre das
eine Agenda die für eine nächste
Bundesregierung schon wichtig wäre eine
Steuerreform bei der man bei der
einkommenenssteuer und bei der
Unternehmenssteuer einfach schaut dass
man das System zukunftsfähig macht